you've grown up in the film industry
what do you see is the future of
filmmaking and film distribution the
next 5 10 20 years I think it's gonna be
like choose your own story stuff you
know I think it's gonna be because I
remember those chooser on story books
when I was younger and I think it's
definitely gonna be like that especially
with I forget what it's called but that
thing that you wear and you can see
completely around you like the oculus
rift there you go with the oculus rift I
think they're gonna make movies where
you are like the first person completely
immersive experiences where you are the
main character of the film and you're
experiencing it and you're going through
this world that is shot entirely in
first-person you know Steadicam stuff
and we have different options that
you're able to do but we shoot it with
Steadicam the entire way that you
possibly can or like with a helmet cam I
think I think that's definitely maybe a
way that things might go I think another
way things might go is you know video
games are becoming much more movie like
so I think you know almost having video
games become semi live-action we saw
them try to do it in the in the early
90s with stuff like Mortal Kombat where
they had like live-action characters put
in a cartoon world and but I think I
think that's I think that might be as
well as the fact that I think we're I
think we're gonna see an influx of
movies that are just John Roos we
haven't seen before because if you look
if you look at recently we had a ton of
we had like mumblecore movies pop-up
before that we had me slice-of-life
films that were popping up we had you
know an influx of movies that were like
callbacks to previous movies from like
the 80s and you know 70s and those
became really popular because of
grindhouse but I think I think we're
really gonna see stuff that is just
interesting stories that people haven't
seen before and I think it's important
to create immersive worlds that people
can get lost in so I think we'll see
something similar to that very soon and
distribution
I think distribution is going all
digital I think it's the only way that
it can survive I think that DVDs are
becoming extinct and it's this is coming
from an avid DVD collector over there
there's a trunk full of maybe five six
thousand DVDs that I've collected over
the years but I even stopped buying DVDs
I started just watching them on Netflix
because what I'm paying for Netflix and
it's up there and I'm watching it it's
kind of hard to also if I've watched it
once or twice on Netflix
it's I go well is this a Netflix movie
or is this a movie I want to own when I
used to just go I'm gonna buy it and
watch it and then that way after I own
it I can choose whether I want to watch
it again or not but I at least have it
and I would be like yay I get to own
this movie and like whether and that was
part of like the joy of it it was like
is it good is it bad I would go to the
blockbuster and buy like you know five
movies from the you know five for 20 bin
and I'd do that all the time and you
know some would be good some would be
bad but now with Netflix you know you
just watch it on there even though I
spend more time on Netflix scrolling
through looking for something to watch
than I do actually watching movies now
do you think theaters will be a thing of
the past or it'll become this really
special event where you have to pay all
this money and there's dinner and it's I
think I think theaters have the
possibility of being both I I go to a
theater called I pick which is in
Pasadena Gould cinemas and they have
dinner in a movie you sit there you eat
dinner you have waiters that come in and
luxurious couches and it's it's really
nice I also go to the ArcLight a lot I
love the ArcLight I think that's like a
tear slightly lower but it's much higher
than you know going to
you know your standard Pacific Theaters
or whatever but then also I love going
with friends to like the second run
theatres we go on
on Tuesdays it's dollar-fifty Tuesday
over at this movie theater where you
could see any movie for a dollar fifty
and it's movies that just left the
theaters so the movies that I didn't pay
to go see for like you know 15 bucks
I'll see it for a dollar fifty with some
friends and we'll see like three of them
back-to-back cuz it's like you know four
dollars and fifty cents and I think I
think that movie theaters will always be
a thing I just think that they're the
studio's are gonna have to scale back on
the amount of movies they're putting out
because I think that viewers have been
overwhelmed with choices because now
when you go out to see a movie on the
weekends you have like six movies that
came out that weekend which are you
gonna see well which one is the one to
do and if you didn't see one of the ones
from last weekend well maybe you want to
see that because the ones from this
weekend are sold out but you didn't see
ones from two weekends ago there's too
many movies coming out right now in
theaters and I think what we need to do
what the studio's need to do is scale
back the amount of movies coming out per
week or per month because I think that's
why they're struggling to do well
because people want to go to the movies
movies are still I mean tickets are
still selling they just want to go to
the movies not as often so they're not
going to want to spend every week
fifteen twenty dollars to see the new
big movie they're gonna say well do I
want to see you know this Marvel movie
blah blah or do I want to see this other
Marvel movie blah blah blah well I want
to see this one it's they make their
choices and so if you give them less
choices I think you'll see ticket sales
go up
you